[Musique]
le collège amiral Bouvet à Saint-Benoist
est le premier collège public de France
a adopter la tenue unique en effet ce
lundi 22 janvier jour de rentrée
scolaire les élèves de ce collège se
sont vu remettre leur tenue qu'ils
devront porter à partir de demain détenu
financé par l'État et le département
afin d'effacer les inégalités il faut
savoir que beaucoup de familles vivent
en dessous du seuil de précarité donc
c'est un moyen pour nous d'atténuer les
dépenses des familles donc de lutter
contre précarité financière le
département finance à parité avec le
rectorat et donc l'état les dépenses
d'acquisition de cette tenue commune
mais je voulais vous dire aussi que
au-delà des aspects financiers c'est
aussi dans un but de faire en sorte de
lutter contre le harcèlement scolaire
parce que quand certains arrivent avec
des vêtements de grande marque et
d'autres avec des vêtements un peu plus
classiques et moins chers cela crée des
inégalités donc c'est un moyen de lutter
contre les inégalités et de lutter
contre le harcèlement scolaire il s'agit
d'une expérimentation qui s'étendra à
une centaine d'établissements en France
hexagonal et en outreem dès cette année
il y aura bien sûr puquil y a une
expérimentation une évaluation cette
expérimentation il y aura pas de
généralisation avant l'évaluation de
cette expérimentation si cette
évaluation scientifique je le précise
par les meilleurs spécialistes est
positive à ce moment-là le président
souhaitera sans doute une généralisation
à la rentrée 2026 une nouvelle qui
semble réjouir collégien comme parents
d'élèv très très très très bien pour moi
je trouve de discrimination tout le
monde va porter la même chose la même
tenue donc c'est vraiment une très très
très très bonne chose pour moi je trouve
voilà après en plus est prise en charge
les tenues donc c'est très très très
très bien c'est c'est plutôt joli c'est
plutôt pratique aussi on se différencie
aussi bien des autres on se mélange et
ça fait moin d'harcement aussi de
jalousie c'est
bien Mo c'est assz pratique comme ça le
matin on a pas besoin de réfléchir à
quel ce qu'on va porter on prend le
t-shirt le short et voilà il y a
l'harcèlement parce qu'il y a des gens
qui aiment pas le site donc ils
harcèlent ah c'est pas bon ah c'est
Desmé donc quand tout le monde aura le
même t-shirt là il y aura plus de
remarque sera un problème en moin pour
le
collège deux autres collèges de lillele
participent à cette expérimentation il
s'agit du collège lachatoire et du
collège le compte de l'Î à
Saint-Louis